you
the first step in learning how to be an
innovator is to understand how the
process works and to learn and to know
what you don't know so it's okay and
actually encouraged to not try to do
everything well and not to say oh I
could be the CEO of a company probably
better not that you're not that's not
the best use of your time but to
understand what it is the CEO would do
so you can find the right person and
you're not feeling completely disjointed
from the business side is important so
some of the things that are important to
understand our how innovations the
diffusion of innovations how they end up
spreading and so other theories of
innovation to understand how to finance
innovation understand some of the legal
aspects particularly intellectual
property and when I talk about that I
don't necessarily mean that everything
needs to be protected with patents in
fact depending on the depending on the
field patents don't make sense at all
because you know maybe copyrights maybe
you don't want to protect it at all
maybe you want to use Creative Commons
and maybe you want to get it out there
as as broadly as possible but you need
to make that decision deliberately it's
better for example to use certain
mechanisms like open source or creative
commons than to just make something
freely available for liability reasons
for example so there's a nuances and
it's important to understand all the
different options before you decide on
that and just and the basic ideas behind
business are important to understand
even if you end up developing a
non-profit you can really benefit from
the thoughts and the ideas behind you
know finance and marketing and
understanding what the competition is
all about those are really valuable
people make a lot of mistakes starting
companies but that's good as long as
they bounce back I think that's one of
the most most common traits of
entrepreneurs successful entrepreneurs
is that they're willing to fail and then
bounce back from it and that's an
important trait of a very successful
entrepreneurial and innovation ecosystem
is for people to accept failure as a
path towards learning so everyone makes
different mistakes and each one of them
are is like a badge of honor I think one
mistake that some people make is to be a
bit too secretive with their idea
because they think that if they give
away their idea then they've lost
everything when in fact the idea is you
know maybe one percent of the solution
and that's what innovation is not just
about the idea but it's about
translating that idea into tangible
impact so one of the ways to do that of
course is to talk to as many people as
possible to get their feedback talk to
customers get their feedback understand
how they do what they do and have it how
you can help them do it better and you
won't do that by being secretive